you know as an attorney right when
you're looking at what the sec is doing
and pat made a great point about okay
like we can't set this up as an
investment well then i can see you know
i'm just a dummy from jersey and i can
see a kafka trap from a mile away okay
well if it's not that if it's not an
investment then it's gambling and you
still need to register with the gaming
commission because you're buying a token
on its lottery essentially you're buying
this thinking that it could go up but
with uh you know no no fail safe if it
goes down either way they're going to
want you to register you either you're
either gambling or you're investing and
they've kind of got you trapped john i
just want to give you full disclaimer
very few dummies from new jersey used
the word kafka trap two seconds after
saying down from new jersey just i just
want to put that out there but go ahead
i appreciate that because i'm still
trying to figure out what it means
i didn't listen to the rest of what he
said after he said that word i'm like
what the hell does that mean
so basically man you you see them
they're trying to corner the token into
regulation yeah first they're going to
go after it as an investment property
right and then you're going to say it's
not an investment property like pat's
saying it's not an investment property
they're going to be like okay well what
what makes it not an investment property
well it it it could bottom out it could
hollow out oh so then you're gambling
right now you need to register his
lottery now you need to register as as
gaming
they're letting your arguments you're
going to win this argument and through
winning this argument give them their
next argument if i learned anything from
doing mafia states of america with the
questions pat asked rudy the government
is taking their losses and turning them
into their next wins right they will
change the law until they have you so
what my concern is with something like
this especially with the settlement
because the settlement makes too much
sense just make it go away the
settlement gets you closer to the
regulation
if it's not going to be this
then they're going to get you the next
time and it's not going to be registered
as a security it's going to be
registered as gaming it's going to have
to be registered to some sort of
gambling you're going to have to be 21
and older to buy it you're going to have
to buy it with certain restrictions like
that's they're going to regulate it some
way or another and we're trying the
whole point of this is the
decentralization and deregulation the
whole point of this is to be outside of
the their scope of control so you know
that that's kind of like now that's not
your concern obviously because your
concern is to win the lawsuit in hand
but
you know and again i didn't know that
you didn't know the guys of ripple but
i'm wondering if they are then
saying would they rather be a security
than be
gaming than be seen as some sort of uh
lottery essence because like you said
there's the technology but then there's
the speculation right and the
speculation right now 97 of the people
don't even know what they're doing
that's that is gambling that's lottery
well one problem in the united states is
that you have so many multiple agencies
it's already regulated
xrp and ripple were registered well
ripple was registered as a money
transmitter and they had they got sued
by the government department of justice
in finson and they had a settlement in
2015 and they paid 700 thousand dollars
and and they were told you have to
register all your sales of xrp through
fencing and that happened in 2015 and
then of course five and a half years
later the sec comes down and says oh by
the way
uh it's also a security right and so
what we really need is congress to step
in
and and and authorize the right agency
to govern cryptocurrencies these are
securities then what's an nft
if the token is a security what's an nft
it
what pat went over
you can imagine many things fit those if
you want
no question about it non-fungible by the
way this is this is why i'm concerned
absolutely this is why i'm concerned
because look joseph kennedy who is he
he's a bootlegger he's the father of the
kennedy it's amazing there hasn't been a
movie made about joking there has to be
i mean
he's a legend okay the kid the guy would
sit down his kids uh in suits and say
which one are you guys going to be a
president first can you imagine like
setting that expectation
for the ira i think you got your next
project
[Laughter]
so
so i've interviewed rfk rfq is a very
good friend uh i think we have something
coming up together debate that we're
doing uh
part two with his book that just came
out with his best friend in regards to
his best friend anthony fauci he loves
anthony fauci uh uh that's a joke by the
way
so
so joseph kennedy
before there's any sec anything going on
the guy just knew pump and dumb pump and
dumb pump and dumb pump and dump
everybody and their mothers was doing it
right
and then security exchange act of 1933
and such an investment company act of
1934 and all these other stuff you know
whatever these these things started
coming out right
right after the great depression was it
a good thing was it a bad thing many
will say was a good thing because guys
during that time capitalized because
there was no regulation
they came in they took money out and you
know the rich got richer and a lot of
people got crushed that couldn't afford
to lose that three thousand dollars or
forty thousand dollars a hundred
thousand dollars or that the
girl you're talking about whose father
passed away in insurance policy paid 75
000 and she put the 75 000 in xrp and
she can't take the money out and that 75
000 is now
whatever 20 000 but she needs that money
she can't touch that money so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]